in the united states half that time to
reach 2 million
43 days 27 days to reach 3 million
people
16 days to reach 4 million
terrible terrible and a congress will
meant you
as i say mr chairman davis thank you
congressman evans
mr kildee and mr chairman neal for
bringing us here we we you know we keep
saying you want to open the schools you
want to open
the economy defeat this virus
and yet and yet and yet delay
distortion denial has taken us to a
place where we have four million people
and there are many other concerns that
we have of state and local government
having to fire
people and the list is a long one of
concerns that we're trying to address
that mr davis
rightly calls really it injustices
and how they disproportionately impact
communities of color
and the rest but right now we are
focusing on this
one subject the extension of the
unemployment
insurance benefit this is central
to the well-being of america's family
what
do the republicans and the white house
have against
working families in our country that
they would begrudge them
six hundred dollars of well absolutely
necessary sustenance this is there are
other things
in here too it's about paying the rent
and it's about buying food
so with this package we have people on
the verge
of eviction we have millions of children
starving food insecure in america
we need the on the food stamps and the
rest and they resent that
we had legislation in the heroes act and
independently
to help with rent so that people are not
evicted
and we have this money and the
unemployment
benefit so i thank the members of the
ways and means committee for always
recognizing always recognizing the
connection between our policy
and the health and livelihood the lives
and livelihood
of america's working families
as again as mr kildee said
we hear calls all the time people
crying on the phone crying on tv crying
they're in pain they're
it's about their dignity and how they
meet the needs of their
children and why
and why because the republicans are
derelict in their duty
taking off for the weekend instead of
being ready all these months
without preparing something to begin
with when we had our offer they make
their offer
now two months and and eight ten days
have gone by
and where are they and where is their
offer which earlier this week they said
we would see in 24 or 48
hours they're in disarray and their
disarray
is causing great great damage to
america's working families
this is an alarm that needs to be
sounded as loudly as possible
about what are we doing here if we are
not
addressing the needs of people who have
lost their jobs
through no fault of their own and as mr
davis said
they tell them to go to work go to work
you're an essential worker you must go
to work
and when you go to work and there are no
protections you have no recourse
and if you don't go to work because
you're afraid that you're going to bring
some
the infection home to your children you
don't get unemployment insurance but mr
mr neil the distinguished chairman he
has always been there for the people
who need it the most as a counter
by the republicans who are there for
people who have
the most so when they talk about six
hundred dollars
i want to review the fact that they put
two trillion dollars onto the national
debt
to give a tax break to the wealth 83
percent of the benefits
to the top one percent i'll close
prayerfully
quoting saint augustine some of you have
heard me say this almost every day
saint augustine seventeen hundred years
ago
he said any government that is not
formed
to promote justice is just a bunch of
thieves let's use our time
to remove all doubt that we're going to
do the right thing by the american
people
so they can meet the needs of their
families
everybody wants to talk about being
family friendly
let's not squawk about 600 with that i
yield back to the descendants chair of
the committee
or whoever's leading the way here
will you pass a bill to invoke a
short-term
renewal of these benefits so that they
don't lapse for americans
but i will tell you this the ways
committee intends next week to hold a
hearing on unemployment insurance
yeah let me just say this we have we
have food stamps in there and they're
like what
you want more money for food stamps we
have housing in there
what you want money for housing we have
this benefit in there
there is i would be very much averse
to separating this out and lose all
leverage for all
meeting all of the other needs it's a
fraudulent
tactic and with all due respect to you
an unworthy question when it comes to
meeting the needs of america's working
families
but we have i'm glad you're having the
hearing to keep the spotlight on it
what is the point of put they could have
done they could have
done their job as you said do your job
uh i mean this is dereliction of duty
and our responsibility the american
people and now we
you're saying why don't you just bail
them out so they can ignore
all the needs that we have for testing
all the needs we have are state and
local government all the needs we have
for food security all the needs we have
for osha benefit
that is in the bill all the needs that
we have uh for
vote by mail and other priorities that
we have
that are about justice
are you considering extending these
benefits for a month or two while you
continue to negotiate
the point being the republicans have
every bit of information they need to
make the decision
legislation if you go through it with
the retention tax credit and all
it's really a good piece of legislative
work
it's a tactic in order not to honor our
other
responsibilities they will not be a
party
to their tactics
given money for education
more money for tpp etc when you bring in
the unemployment insurance benefit of
another 600
do you think it is possible to extend
extend
that benefit at that level and keep a
bill within a trillion dollars
and what we said to the republican i'm
going to tell you something
this is deadly serious a house is
burning down
in terms of the economic security of
america's families
and these people are fiddling wherever
they may be
this weekend so when you talk about
well they want to do a trillion dollars
so how can we do six hundred dollars
for those in the most need when when
they got other things they want to do
but that's why chuck and the
distinguished leader and i said to them
put your bill on paper put your bill
on paper and then we'll see what you
have included and what you have left out
and then the american people will see
what you have included
and what you have left out but i'm
telling you
you can't have any more patience you
know it's a it's a wonderful thing i
read
it's amazing how much patience people
can have
with other people suffering well we
don't have that patience
on our side of the aisle and so for them
to say a trillion dollars
when they spent two trillion dollars to
give a tax cut to the richest people in
america eighty-three percent of the
benefits
to the top one percentage and they
borrowed it they
heaped it on the backs of our children
for future generations so
let us see what their trillion dollars
gets them and what are they excluding
they have nothing for state and local
where people are
working health care professionals food
suppliers
transit workers teachers teachers
teachers sanitation
people who make a system run
over a million and a half of them have
been fired already because
of the needs of a coronavirus the
expenses
of coronavirus and the revenue lost
because of corona
take that out let those people go okay
so now
they don't have jobs they probably have
to go on unemployment
right so what money have they saved and
then we have testing testing testing
they shut down their cafeteria the
minute somebody got a
uh infected in the uh uh
white house complex they shut it down
they're testing and tracing
why can't they put that money there for
the states in a substantial way with a
strategic plan
to do that so what money do they have
there for that
then we have the money for for uh rental
assistance and mortgage forbearance
and uh um food stamps as i keep saying
the one thing i just can't understand is
how they could even show their faces by
saying
food stamps you want more money for food
stamps why would we
why would we do that well because people
are hungry
in america doesn't that motivate you so
a trillion dollars that our bill 3.4
mean and lean it's everything we need
it's nothing
extra so let's see where their
trillion dollar takes them and not have
them use that as a reason why they can't
give
america's working family six six hundred
dollars
don't get me started on that 600
i think it's important it's important to
note though even if somehow
even if somehow the republicans can't
conjure some empathy
for these families which is hard to
comprehend
they ought to at least be able to
comprehend the fact that to the extent
that this economy has been barely held
together
it's because these families have had
this unemployment benefit
and the spending power to go down to the
corner grocery store
and to pay their rent and to take care
of their families that money goes
directly into the u.s economy
so even if they can't figure out a way
to have sympathy and empathy
for the families that would be hurt and
harmed so much by this
they ought to at least enroll in an
entry level economics class and
understand if you take that money out of
the economy
this whole house of cards is going to
collapse and that's why they need to act
now
thank you on the issue of price tag um
the heroes act passed two months ago
plus and conditions have changed on the
ground obviously and it would make more
money
that's that was my question is 3.4
enough given that a lot of
a lot of parts of the country are
suffering more than they were two months
ago
and where would where would that be i
know you mentioned that education could
you
i may use your question but to pivot
from what mr kelde was saying
we are a consumer economy our economy it
grows and succeeds and is strengthened
by the comp the consumer confidence that
is there
they should know that at the same time
as they are spending
trillions of dollars to bolster the
stock market
so it has a floor and that's not a bad
thing
we should be spending trillions of
dollars to have a floor
for america's working families because
it's the right thing to do
but it's also the most a pragmatic thing
to do
in order where you put money into
businesses if there's
you ain't got no customers it's no use
having money to pay the rent and the
staff if you want if there's no business
so this money
is spent it's necessary needed it's
spent it injects demand into the economy
and it creates jobs so i just wanted to
go back to your point
okay on education for example we need
much more money we had a hundred billion
dollars in for education
we all we we also knew that that wasn't
really quite enough
but we were trying to be lean and mean
with the budget
and um um they came in with 105 this
week and they said well you have 500
but of course you have to see where they
want to spend that money
but we probably need double that much at
least double that much
for education for one thing but by and
large
um we have we're we're in pretty good
shape with
what we have in the budget if we could
spend it now now they want to do zero
for state and local
really tell it to the governors and
mayors
acros county executives across the
country
uh we have to have that money they're
not going to be at a trillion dollars
and if you see their trillion dollar
list
it's really going to be a big
embarrassment to the republican party
to see who they cut out and who they
include and how they were willing to
spend double that
for a tax cut for their rich friends
anybody
i heard you say
um directed to you but anybody can
answer and i'm following up on nancy's
question
i heard you say no multiple times but
isn't this issue on a different level in
the sense that it is immediate it is
going to expire and that some of the
other things while
also important funding for elections
and funding for education isn't going to
have the the effect that
mr kildee has described his constituents
are worried about
well if you were going to be evicted at
the end of this month you might not
think the same way
if you were crying because you couldn't
put food on the table for your children
you might be thinking a different way
that's why we have to have
these actually a safety net
for the capitalist system everybody says
safety network
it's a capitalist system safety net so
that they can wheel and deal and free
wing
and then in the cycle of things when
people
need help there's a safety net for the
capital
the table so this is very important
so you want to have you want to see how
many people will be on the street being
evicted because they
cannot pay the rent
and then they can't pay the rent
exponentially because they're not
getting the 600
i'm just going to lighten up the mood
here
i'm going to tell you this all right
carl reiner great you know you're all
too young to know but he was a great
comedian
right and his son rob reiner meathead
maybe you're too young for that as well
anyway he died a great comedian in his
90s 98 years old
so i called his son rob
who is a comedian too i called rob
rob rob darling
this is nancy pelosi i'm calling to wish
you and michelle
my condolences i'm so sad your father
was so funny and so wonderful i had the
occasion to hear them remember
this man says i think you have the wrong
number
i said really i'm so sorry i thought
this was rob reiner's he said well you
know i know who carl reiner is and i no
railroaders
but i think you have the wrong number i
said well i'm so sorry
whether i talk to my staff about this
[Laughter]
and he says but i'm so glad you called
me
i have one question for you i said what
is that
he said am i going to get my 600 dollars
i'm very proud of her i thought it was
great i we're daughters
two great two granddaughters and uh i
thought she was just great
it was you know what she said is what we
all know
a president of the united states who
gives license to people to speak that
way
who are at ease with that kind of
disrespect
condescension and the rest and in
keeping what the president was saying
about his fear-mongering for
a woman who lived in suburbia and how he
treated that fear-mongering
dis uh discrimination
disrespect condescension i was very
proud of her
thank you all very much
what's the sheer number of patients
we've had to take care of
at the end of life has been overwhelming
and surreal to say the least
not everybody